En gare de Vendôme-Villiers, il y a des trains
qui passent et d'autres qui s'arrêtent.
C'est ce qu'aurait du faire le TGV numéro
8304 parti à 7h11 de Tours mardi matin.
Sauf que voilà, suite à un problème de
saisie du numéro de train au centre de gestion
de la circulation, le conducteur n'avait pas
la bonne feuille de route.
Son train n'était donc pas programmé pour
s'arrêter à Vendôme.
A proximité de la cité loir-et-cherienne,
le conducteur s'est toute fois aperçu de
l'erreur, mais compte tenu des procédures
de freinage, il n'a pu s'arrêter à temps.
La gare de Vendôme est derrière lui, le
train est en pleine voie, il a donc du descendre,
remonter la rame jusqu'à la motrice de queue
pour faire repartir son TGV, direction la
gare de Vendôme.
Une fois en gare, il a du répéter la manœuvre
dans l'autre sens, afin de partir cette fois-ci
pour Paris-Montparnasse.
Conséquence pour les voyageurs, une arrivée
à Paris avec 37mn de retard.
Ils pourront être remboursés à hauteur
de 25% du prix de leur billet.